[Music]
that's three generations of the Johnson
family hitting the carpet Dwayne brought
his mom Atta and sixteen-year-old
daughter Simone as dates at home for the
night girlfriend Lauren and their two
daughters we're just constantly texting
each other checking in always facetiming
we have a three-month-old at home at two
and a half-year-old home and I'm a big
baby too at home like Lauren does a
tremendous job I'm really so proud of
her she is just a super mom I tell her
all the time I'm like you're my
superwoman baby
the couple of ten years welcome baby TIA
in April cutest thing is just when I
hold her and then if she throws up on me
and cute things like that who's
beautiful Dwayne's co-star Neff Campbell
is also adjusting to life with a new
baby
she and longtime partner JJ field
recently adopted son Rainer they already
have a six-year-old Caspian but the
couple snuck away for a parents night
out and the point four year old
glittered in a beaded gold Gandolfi
supercrime
in skyscraper Dwayne plays a dad
determined to save his family from a
burning building and he uses a lot of
duct tape so when I saw him in Hong Kong
last week I brought a little gift for
baby Tia the cameras are on right so yes
she tried the onesie on it was fantastic
she told me to tell you guys thank you
so much amazing yeah
[Music]